hello everyone and welcome to a really
big clash from round 15 of the world
blitz championship it's magnus cross and
versus anishigiri uh let's dive straight
into it but before i show it for those
of you who do not know and i am getting
a lot of requests to show the game
daniel dubo versus hikaru nakamura
but nakamura contracted kovid and he is
not playing today so that's why it's
funny but yeah for those of you who
didn't know that now you have been
informed by the hadoop of one dead game
but just playing e4 so it's um uh well
definitely one of the shortest games
ever played uh so getting back to this
one magnus opens with e4 we have e5 by
anish knight to f3 knights the c6 and
now bishop to b5 going for the real opus
uh he knows that anish is a a great uh
joko piano expert so he doesn't want to
go into that knight to f6 and now d3 we
have bishop to c5 and now bishop
captures on c6 d captures in just castle
so this is a
well known line of the berlin we have
bishop to g4 and now bishop to g5 uh
pinning this knight we have h6 and
magnus goes back bishop to h4 and now
queen to e7 anish prefers the castle
queen side knight to b to d2 and here uh
he does castle queen side and now there
is a game where a3 was played magnus
decides for a bishop to g3 and it is now
as a move tender we have a completely
new game uh so knights to d7 adding a
defender to d5 pawn uh but also just
preparing to remaneuver this bishop
maybe the knight is coming to c5 also
you'll be able to push f5 all depends on
what white plays so c3 are preparing to
push those queen side pawns but also uh
preparing maybe queen to a4 uh we have
king to b8 so the a7 pawn will not be
vulnerable and now b4 uh we have bishop
to d6 you don't want to play bishop b6
then you just give white free tempe to
advance the a pawn so bishop back to d6
and now we have a4 uh we have g5 and he
starts pushing on the king side which is
normal we have castles on opposite sides
of the board magnus plays b5 and now c5
you don't want to open up the queen side
as well you're attacking on the king
side so a5 and now h5 preparing h4 to
trap the bishop so magnus pushes h4
himself g captures with bishop captures
attacking the queen and f6 now
we have queen to b3 by magnus
uh preparing to bring the other rook
into the attack and now rook h to g8
now as the bishop moves uh at some point
the king is on g1 so maybe you could use
this or maybe uh if just let's say
knight to c4 which is a move you really
want to play at some point then just
bishop captures and f3 you're not going
to be able to capture back so bishop to
g3 putting something uh in between the
king and the rook and now bishop back to
e6 attacking the queen
and now queen to a4 now this was a good
moment to finally get this knight to c4
but magnus decides against that he plays
queen to a4 first and now we have rook
to g4
uh so what do you play here uh of course
anish wants to double up on the g file
and also this will give him some support
for pushing h4 at some point maybe he
wants to play f5 h4 so knight to h2
attacking the rook rook back to g7 and
now knight d to f3 again this knight was
maybe better suited than c4 rook d to g8
and now comes knight to h4 so it seems
that magnus has very nice control over
the king side that you can't push the h
point you have very nice control of the
f5 square the rooks aren't all that
useful however the position is
completely winning for a niche but you
have to find a very specific move so
feel free to pause the video and find
this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is pawn
to c4 yes sometimes to uh have a
successful attack on the kings side we
must first attack the queen side and now
what do you do here magnus played d
captures on c4 but even let's say just
advancing isn't all that impressive for
example captures captures f5 uh and uh
well there are all sorts of uh threats
possible here uh for example if you play
d5 attack the bishop we can just play
bishop captures and g3 if f captures
rook captures you can even give up the
bishop because the knight here is
hanging and there really isn't anything
good for white here for example captures
captures and you're dead lost here the
rook captures on g2 is coming and
there's no way to
do anything about this uh so instead
after c4 magnus played the d captures on
c4 but this is not much better we have
knight to c5 attacking the queen and the
e4 pawn queen to c2 to defend e4 pawn
and now queen to f7 you could also
capture on c4 right away but anish wants
to prepare it we have b6 now by magnus
uh he he is definitely out of out of
move so he has to try something
c captures on b6 a captures and of
course anish closes the queen side with
a6 and now rook f the d1
we have bishop to a7 getting the bishop
out of harm's way and now again magnus
without a useful move he tries rook to
d5 and it's a very good try uh putting
pressure on black's position and
preparing to double up here also uh well
the knight is attacked if the bishop
ever moves so uh you don't have to
capture this rogue because for the
moment it has uh really no threats but
anish captures it as well it's it's a
three minute blitz game you don't have
time to calculate everything c captures
on d5 and now bishop the d8 going after
the b6 spawn knight to f5 magnus got a
very nice square for his knight by
eliminating uh gear is a light square
bishop we have rook to g6 and now knight
to f3 uh we have queen to b7 uh and now
comes uh knight three to h4 attacking
the rook here rook to g4 attacking this
pawn uh this is a well a real weakness
in the position and the this rook the g4
move is just beautiful by geary if we go
one one move back he had to play queen
to
d7 first because he doesn't want his
queen on f7 because after a move like
rogue g4 you can play knight h6 and then
both of the rooks and the queen will be
attacked this way he's offering the
exchange but it will completely shatter
white's position so magnus goes for
knight to the h6 but now knight captures
an e4 magnus grabs the rook on g8 now
comes knight captures on g3 and uh here
uh magnus just decided to capture back
even though you could grab this pawn
because you're going to lose this knight
either way but it doesn't really do all
that much for you so magnus decides
against that he just plays f captures on
g3 bishop captures on b6 with check and
in between move before we grab the
knight and g8 king h2 rook captures ng8
and now rook to b1 magnus will try to do
some damage on the b file but now bishop
to c5 and here we have c4 now here if
magnus could play knight to f5 and queen
to e4 uh his position would be well
would be maybe even playable but uh the
d5 point is hanging so he first defends
it and now of course anish will not give
him time to play knight five and queen
e4 he just goes queen to g4 uh now the
queen will not be cut off from the game
and now rook to b3 magnus defends the b3
pawn but again the position is
completely lost so uh once again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing it was
yet another pawn push to the fourth rank
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show now it's pawn to e4 so
yes first pause the video moment point
c4 now pawn to e4 that's uh you know
if there was a pawn to g4 i'd make
another positive video moment but there
isn't uh and with this move anish
prepares bishop to d6 adding a third
attacker to the g3 pawn and that's just
it you will not be able to hold this uh
magnus tries queen to b2 and now just
bishop to d6 anish doesn't care about
the b7 pawn falling of course you can't
just add another defender to the g3 pawn
because
we just captured the knight we don't
really care that you're defending the g3
pawn so magnus goes after the b7 pawn
but anish doesn't care he just captures
rook captures on b7 king the a8 and
there's no way to follow up uh with um
any any checks here or any tricks here
if you try there's nothing to try really
if you play queen b6 threat and
checkmate we can just play queen
captures on g3 and once the king moves
for example queen e1 checkmate uh the
bishop covers the h2 square so magnus
goes back rook b3 to add another
defender here but now anish plays bishop
captures and g3 check and he was in this
position on 43 that magnus carlsen
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you could also
capture the knight that's perfectly fine
but this is much more precise as there's
really nothing to do for example rook
captures queen captures king to g1 we're
going to capture the knight with check
as well so we don't give white any
chance for for a counter play for
example kg1 queen e1 check king h2 and
now we can just play e3 and there's no
counter play here because the white
queen can never move away from the
defense of the g2 pawn and other than
that you really have no moves for if you
try this then we just checkmate you and
that's it if you don't then you have no
moves so really impressive game a nice
win against the the reigning world blitz
champion uh in the in this very nice
fine line of the of the real lopez and
with the black pieces uh
uh nonetheless uh so yeah a great game
by anish i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank eat franco's dot com
shirley chung uh george julie and j lola
boone uh christian hoggle and drew
watkins for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
tournament uh until it ends
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day